great everyone I'm Ilana and today I
actually wanted to talk about depression
I think this is my first time talking
about this publicly and it is a odd
thing to talk about the reason I wanted
to talk about it right now is because
someone I know launched a Kickstarter
then I'm really inspired by about video
games and mental health and I thought
this is kind of a good time to share my
story and I will talk about that at the
end before I say anything else I want to
stress that my experience with
depression is mine alone everyone
experiences mental health problems
completely differently so please do keep
that in mind so I first got depression
when I was I think 18 and it was kind of
as a result of a sort of PTSD
circumstance for me and I didn't really
have an understanding of what depression
was because most of my exposure to it
had been from mainstream media on movies
which painted it to me as though I would
be sad or crying or suicidal and that
for me just wasn't the case I didn't
know I was depressed for a really long
time because I didn't know what
depression actually was and I think the
day I figured out that I was depressed
was my mom came into my room it was 4:00
p.m. she had just gotten home from work
and she said get out of bed and I
wholeheartedly Oscar why depression for
me was I mean it was crippling
depression I had no desire to move or do
anything or make myself participate in
my own life at all I kind of pictured it
in my head as though I was sitting in a
corner holding this little bulb and
there's this black fog that just keeps
growing and coming at me and trying to
get rid of that bulb and I'm just
holding it in my hands and looking up at
this impossible fog and just not having
any desire to move against it I'm
feeling like I can't like it's just a
wall so for me depression wasn't sadness
I didn't cry it was a complete absence
of self that period of my life is
basically static
it may as well have not have existed at
all and if you can really think about
that that's why depression is so hard to
get out of that's why when someone says
just cheer up it doesn't make any sense
in that kind of situation mental
is not a choice well I actually don't
think I wanted to be happy at that
period of time because I didn't want
anything even if I did it's not like I
could make that happen because this fog
just keeps coming in and in and in so
the way that I actually got through it
was kind of lucky I was still living at
home I was really young and I had
parents who believed me into doing stuff
they got sick of me living this
non-existent life and just straight up
made me get a job I think that mine aliy
helped but the thing that helped me move
in anything was exercised I think this
is another thing that my mom actually
specifically made me do and that helped
me so so much and without my parents and
that position of authority telling me to
do something I mean not feeling like I
could say no because I didn't even have
to fight in me to rebel against anything
I don't know how I would have gotten out
of it at all so it went away and then
sometimes came back but uh one of the
most recent experiences I had where it
really affected me was at the Sun of
last year I was in the stage of culture
shock where I was super sick I got sick
and ultimately got pneumonia so in the
period where I was already really sad
being away from my family who I am
incredibly close to and the one thing
that was kind of distracting me was that
I got to go to work and welcome cool
stuff and meet new people and get to
know the people in my office but then I
got pneumonia and I had to take a full
two weeks off of work at the worst
possible time and it almost killed me it
was really awful and really unfortunate
and I was on codeine I wasn't allowed to
leave the house I couldn't drive I
couldn't do very much at all I didn't
really have an appetite so it was like
full depression almost in that same time
though the witness came out and I truly
believe the witness the video game saves
me from falling back into crippling
depression for anyone doesn't know it is
a challenging puzzle game you walk
around these beautiful colorful
environments and solve puzzles that
teach you how to solve other puzzles in
the same game sort of like it has its
own language so it was something that
was teaching me constantly and I was
learning constantly and most importantly
I felt like I was still accomplishing
things and had
goals to strive towards which is
something that I think video games do
better than pretty much any other medium
the witness being a puzzle game is a
perfect example but they've definitely
been other times in my life where video
games and the sense of accomplishment
you get from them even from completing a
mundane side quest in an MMO you still
feel a spark and you don't have to be
totally able-bodied and you don't have
to go anywhere and it's almost like a
passive way to elevate your mental
health or at least that's how it works
for me and I really believe there are
terrible times that video games have
helped me with more than anything else
more than human interaction just more
than anything so I wanted to tell you
guys about this Kickstarter this is my
mad I wasn't asked to make this video
this is just something that I really do
care about it's called the checkpoint
series and it's basically a webseries
it's raising awareness about mental
health issues and helping those affected
using the power of video games so talked
about how mental health issues are the
single biggest cause of disability in
young people and the single biggest
cause of death of people under 30 years
old through thoughts of those people
know to get help because it's
stigmatized and they feel bad about it
because it's too expensive all because
they don't know they have the problem
and I definitely feel like I personally
sat in that category and it sucked but
they also want to help people to
recognize common problems in other
people and also in video games so
something the series is going to explore
that I'm really interested in is how
mental health is represented in video
games specifically and how we can use
games to learn more about these kinds of
things so I mean you guys can read the
whole thing on Kickstarter I'll leave a
link below but it's something that I
think is awesome
and I guess that is pretty much it for
this video anyone else has similar
stories I would absolutely love to hear
mental health is something that we
should take just as seriously as
physical health and that is it for me
today you guys I will see y'all next
time
bye